liebes tagebuch am montag habe ich das
fünfte türchen aufgemacht es war
schokolade drin
dann dachte ich das ist geschneit hätte
aber leider war es nur eis danach habe
ich mich fürs drehen geschminkt henry
fand mich schön thomas nicht dann musste
ich meine küche aufräumen und ich habe
alles hin gestellt was ich brauche so
sieht es übrigens hinter der kamera aus
hmmm das ist schokolade
es hat so lange gedauert da wurde ich
richtig müde und das sind die pralinen
und das musste ich alles abwaschen
später habe ich noch gekocht
es gab mediterrane nudeln mit oliven und
rucola
danach haben wir youtube videos geschaut
und die katzen haben auf mir geschlafen
und dann haben max und ich lustige
gesichter gemacht
[Musik]
das ist so lustig
hallo
[Musik]
dann haben wir den laufenden tod
geschaut mein bett ist so gemütlich da
schlafe ich immer sofort ein
am dienstag waren nikolaus wieder habe
ich das sechste türchen aufgemacht
es waren zwei überraschungen bringen und
eine karte mal schauen was es ist
es war schokolade karamell führung um
dann habe ich telefonate geführt und
eine mandarine gegessen
unser katzenberger hat wenz kranz ist
sehr schön
[Musik]
später habe ich das pralinen video
geschnitten und tee getrunken
als das video fertig war habe ich es
getestet
[Musik]
und danach hochgeladen dann hatte ich
migräne um thomas hat mich getröstet
davon wurde er müde und max hat mini
brote geschmiert handy lag auf dem
rücken und sah dabei richtig süß aus
[Musik]
dann haben wir die man gewinnt challenge
ausprobiert da darf man sich nicht
bewegen
[Musik]
das können wir gut
am dienstag habe ich das siebte türchen
aufgemacht
es war schokolade drin anna kamen vorbei
damit wir zusammen videos drehen können
ich mag an heute ist donnerstag und ich
konnte das achte türchen öffnen es war
schokolade drin
nach dem duschen hatte ich richtig nasse
haare danach habe ich meinen
kleiderschrank ausgemistet und mir ist
aufgefallen dass ich eine neue haarfarbe
brauchen dann canucks mit einem paket
nach hause und jemand und henry haben
mir geholfen das paket zu öffnen
es war schokolade drin spaß
es war meine erste eigene regenjacke und
ein ohne sie von der firma ohne diese
ende
ich habe keine gesichter mehr